confirming that we received helicopter
data products
for more than three hours nasa engineers
waited anxiously for the signal of
success
from 179 million miles away
engineers reporting having performed
landing
touchdown and spin down
then came the first video their mini
helicopter flying
three meters above the martian surface
taking a snap of its shadow
and safely touching down in the red dust
an historic flight
of 39.1 seconds we can now say that
human beings have flown a rotorcraft on
another planet
this was nasa's wright brothers moment
just 117 years ago
orville and wilbur flew for the first
time on earth
a patch of fabric from that plane was
taped to ingenuity for luck
the landing gear fiesta worked well all
these server mechanisms and motors are
doing great the computers and the
avionics behaved
flawlessly so all in all it's in a
perfect state
and i'm just really excited to see what
all she can teach us over the next few
weeks
ingenuity weighs the same as two bags of
sugar with twin rotors
120 centimetres long too far away to be
controlled from earth
the helicopter had to fly autonomously
coping with mars's gusting winds on its
own
and overcome some challenging physics
a drone flies by pushing down on a
cushion
of air but mars's atmosphere is just one
percent of the density of our own it's
so thin it's barely there so to hover
above the planet's surface
ingenuity's rotors spin 40 times a
second
perseverance rover is taking a break
from its search for signs of ancient
life to test out what could be an aerial
scout
on future missions perhaps one day even
guiding astronauts
the idea is to to fly it to different
locations to be able to
effectively sort of test the boundaries
of what you can really do in such a thin
atmosphere
with with this type of thing so the idea
is to test this for future missions
a successful flight on mars now gives
nasa a new
tool to explore the solar system thomas
more sky news